do you know how to ethically collect and
use personal data for your business by
gathering this data you've taken on a
responsibility to protect the privacy of
those whose data you gather
in data privacy and technology we will
consider the many definitions of privacy
and their implications for individuals
corporations and governments
we will explore what personal privacy
means how data is collected and used the
trade-offs between privacy and other
values and look to the future your data
can and will outlive you it will be
there forever it just seems ridiculous
to not try to protect this most valuable
asset this course is crucial for
businesses today because of the changing
nature of our world you will immerse
yourself in real world challenges faced
by industry-leading experts and explore
the legal and ethical implications of
collecting user and customer data when
you think about it in a larger sense
our personal information really is the
fuel
for these corporations there are just so
many different interests and so many
different issues it's not just how do i
deliver anonymous data privacy is a
complex and multi-faceted concept by the
end of the course you should be able to
apply your learning to your life your
role and your business
it's time to learn how to balance the
utility of a data set with the privacy
of the individuals do you agree to
enroll in this course
[Music]